Ça a voir avec la connexion.
Et on ne peut pas être à l'aise avant d'être mal à l'aise.
Il faut le faire, tout simplement.
Quant aux jeunes Noirs, ce que je vous dis,
c'est que si on vient à votre rencontre, sincèrement, acceptez l'invitation.
Tout le monde n'est pas là pour avoir votre peau.
Allez chercher ces gens qui peuvent voir votre humanité.
C'est l'empathie et la compassion
générée par les relations avec des gens différents de vous.
Quelque chose de puissant et de magnifique apparaît.
Vous commencez à réaliser qu'ils sont vous,
qu'ils sont une part de vous, qu'ils sont dans votre famille.
Alors nous cessons d'être spectateurs,
et nous devenons des acteurs, des défenseurs,
et des alliés.
Éloignez-vous de votre zone de confort
pour quelque chose de plus grand, de plus lumineux.
C'est comme ça que nous allons empêcher un autre Ferguson.
C'est comme ça que nous créons une communauté,
où tout le monde, en particulier les jeunes Noirs, peuvent s'épanouir.
Cette dernière réflexion est plus dure à entendre,
et je le sais, mais je vais quand même vous la présenter.
Lorsque nous voyons quelque chose,
nous devons trouver le courage de dire quelque chose,
même à ceux que l'on aime.
Nous sommes en vacances et c'est le moment
où nous sommes réunis à table et où nous passons un bon moment.
La plupart d'entre nous est en vacances
et nous devons écouter les conversations.
Vous commencez à dire des choses comme :
« Grand-mère est un cul-bénit. »
(Rires)
« Oncle Joe est raciste. »
Mais nous aimons grand-mère et oncle Joe. Nous les aimons.
Nous savons que ce sont des gens bien, mais ce qu'ils disent est mauvais.
Nous devons dire quelque chose, parce savez-vous qui d'autre est à table ?
Les enfants sont à table.
Et on se demande pourquoi ces préjugés ne meurent pas,
et se transmettent de génération en génération.
C'est parce que l'on ne dit rien.
Nous devons dire : « Grand-mère, on n'appelle plus les gens comme ça. »
« Oncle Joe, ce n'est pas vrai qu'il a mérité ça.
Personne ne mérite ça. »
Nous devons être prêts
à ne pas protéger nos enfants de la laideur du racisme
lorsque les parents de couleur n'ont pas ce luxe,
en particulier ceux qui ont des jeunes garçons.
Nous devons prendre nos chers enfants, notre futur,
leur dire qu'ils ont un pays formidable,
avec des idéaux incroyables,
que nous avons travaillé dur, que nous avons fait des progrès,
mais ce n'est pas terminé.
Nous avons toujours en nous ces vieilles histoires
de supériorité et en conséquence,
elles s'installent plus profondément dans nos institutions,
dans notre société et nos générations.
Elles apportent désespoir, disparités,
et une dévalorisation accablante des jeunes Noirs.
Il faut leur dire que nous luttons toujours
à voir à la fois la couleur,
et la vraie nature des jeunes Noirs.
Il faut leur dire que vous attendez d'eux
qu'ils fassent partie des agents du changement dans cette société
qui s’élèvera contre l'injustice
et qui est prête, avant toute chose,
à construire une société
où les jeunes Noirs sont vus dans leur globalité.
Il y a tant de d'hommes formidables et qui sont noirs,
de ceux qui sont les hommes d'états les plus formidables
qui aient jamais existé,
des soldats courageux,
des travailleurs formidables et dédiés à leur tâche.
Ce sont des gens qui sont des pasteurs influents.
Ce sont des scientifiques, des artistes et des écrivains incroyables.
Ce sont des humoristes audacieux.
Ce sont des grand-pères dévoués,
des fils aimants.
Ce sont des pères solides,
et ce sont des jeunes hommes avec des rêves.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)